first thing we got to go do is check the
Big Joe herd they've been in the Burn
Unit since the post working I had this
little inspiration to bring back the
Wild Turkey population here you don't
want to keep them in a small pin we need
to do something different so muris and I
just got something we're moving our
turkeys in it
today hey guys welcome back to cross
timers bison I want to thank happy
Farmer for sponsor today's video Marissa
AR super excited if you guys don't
already know we rais wild turkeys so
mariss and I just got something that's
going to make a huge difference for our
turkey ranching first thing we got to go
check the Big Joe herd like I said
they've been in the burn unit for about
a week or two we've checked them on them
we checked on them several times but I'm
going to take them some hay and I'm
going to try to move them to the 9 acres
and then into pasture 4 which is where
recently we've been cleaning out a pond
in there because it was completely dry
well two large rains have surprised us
so much and filled the sucker up which
means now we can rotate our bison in
there they can start Grazing In that
pasture since it's had rest they'll have
water now in their new cleaned out Pond
and also I'm going to give them some
grassy alphaalpha and some native hay
roll it out for them have plenty of to
munch
on so the Big Joe herd hasn't seen the
feed truck in a couple of weeks so I bet
they're excited to see me I see them
right here over the
hill oh yeah here they come
what are you doing over
here silly boy
so what's interesting here is I just
rolled out two bells of hay so what
we're doing is I'm rolling out some hay
just kind of giving them plenty to eat
what I did was I rolled out two bells of
hay over there some long strips on some
grass that uh some ground that needs to
be covered it's some very short grazed
low grass and so I'm trying to get some
coverage on it but so I rolled out a
native and then I rolled out alphaalpha
and then to kind of draw them back back
in from the Burn Unit obviously it
worked and then I this morning I just
rolled out a native hay and then I
rolled out Alfalfa Bill and so I rolled
all that out they've got plenty to eat
it's all spread out everywhere for them
the interesting thing is I rolled out
that native over there and maybe it's
just because I'm over here and this
goofy guy but I rolled out the this
right here is Grassy
Alfalfa right through here and so far
that's what they're liking so that's
interesting it's good to know that
they're liking this grassy alphaalpha
it's got a little bit more protein in it
actually it has a lot more protein in it
we've got anywhere from 20 to 24% on
this grassy alphalpha compared to the
native hay I rolled out there um which
that cow she's over there eating it um
which is about 6 or 7% protein so that's
good stuff and get them through the
winter and they need this protein
especially uh when we're getting our
first days of freezing
so just give you a little background
information what we did is I had this
little inspiration to bring back the
Wild Turkey population here in southern
Oklahoma especially here at the
Ponderosa used to be lots of wild
turkeys and when I say wild turkeys I'm
talking about the Easterns and mostly
the Rio Grands I want to try to
contribute and get the turkey population
going again here so what I did was is in
April and May of 2024 I bought some wild
turkey eggs online had them shipped to
us we incubated them and out of the 30
we only had seven struggled a little bit
I heard that wild turkeys are hard to
incubate and hatch out so we only ended
up with seven so our goals kind of
Switched a little bit we've got three
hands and four Toms and what we wanted
to do with that as we kind of changed
our mind we said well we're going to
keep them we asked you guys and you
recommended this we kept these adults
and we're going to wait till the spring
again when these hens hopefully start
laying eggs for the first time ever
we're going to keep the eggs we're going
to incubate them we're going to do a
better job and hopefully get a big group
of turkeys and then we'll let a big
flock of them go out here on the
Ponderosa yes wild turkeys and bison
back together again that's what we're
doing so what we did was is mariss and I
we don't want to keep them in a small
pin which we've had them there for a
while and I said we need to do something
different I like the mobile units I
wanted to try to do something where we
can move them around right they're wild
turkeys let's do the best we can to keep
them wild essentially living off the
land with some help from us right some
feed some clean water those things uh
because this is basically our breeding
stock here and so what we did as we
reached out to the mobile chicken coups
from Happy farmer this is what we got it
is going to be so awesome we're going to
show you guys all the things that we can
do with this we're going to move it
around the Ponderosa so this mobile
chicken unit from Happy farmer came in
on a big 18-wheeler semi truck my skid
steer was actually out in the field so I
used the Hydro Bed to unload this long
pallet of all the parts and all the
equipment to set up this mobile chicken
unit so the next thing was is to put
this thing together so we could get
these turkeys in there as quick as
possible Marissa and I did this together
I would highly recommend using at least
two people for this project just because
this is a 10x8 mobile unit we got one of
the largest mobile units just because
we're dealing with a a larger bird
instead of just chickens this is
definitely made for chickens there's
several different sizes on the happy fer
website that you can pick from but
Marissa and I put this together t teamed
it and it actually wasn't bad at all
took a little bit of time working
together obviously start with the sides
got the sidewalls completed got our
angles then we started putting on our
Rafters and then the main beam of course
you're going to get the instructions
there's also some videos online that
Marissa and I used to kind of get an
idea of what it was supposed to look
like and how it's supposed to put
together so we did use the videos online
as well all the bolts and nuts come in
separate packages and they're marked for
you so you know what bolts you're going
to be using for different parts of this
pin once we got the door on and the main
hole frame of this chicken pin built we
moved it a little bit closer to the barn
where we actually going to move our
turkeys in it so we didn't have to take
the turkeys very far and we're going to
put them in an area where we're going to
be able to rotate kind of around the
front yard sort of inside the pond D Roa
but of course what makes this mobile is
how these tires come up and down this is
a neat and easy concept that they came
up with and this thing is not heavy at
all this whole system is so light I can
already tell it's going to be a great
way for us to move the turkeys around so
once we did that we got it set
stationary and then we put the tarp this
is a heavy duty tarp and I think it will
last a long time two three
four it's pretty
simple Brooks and her cousin AJ are out
here with us helping us put on this
canvas and then they're going to help us
move these turkeys to their new PIN all
right now's the time we got the turkey
pin completely built we're not going to
mess with the water system right now
because uh we're in freezing
temperatures and looks like a really
awesome and nice water system so we're
not going to mess with it right now but
it'll be very handy and super nice
especially in the warmer temperatures
but we've got to get the turkeys out of
this pin and move them into their new
mobile pin we can't wait to do that so
this is the uh fun part getting in with
these uh wild
turkeys okay girl
hey about had an escape artist good
night Nancy
one are you good with just taking one at
a time one at a I think that sounds like
a good idea I got seven I know I don't
want to be responsible for the
uh
and I got
ni I'm going to watch
it go get the bucket out of
[Applause]
there
I
bullet okay y'all wait right okay here
get that chain
off I see tag on it okay Brooks you come
over here h no okay you stay
there what in the head well you got to
get the gate you got to get this gate oh
that
gate okay you stay right here and you
open this gate for us all right don't
let horses out
Manza yeah they get fired up they have
gotten
big yeah they have gotten
big strong very strong
oh stronger than a
chicken you got
it watch their talent do they have
talons yeah okay got it yep okay right
UND delay in case they see the
Escape okay
bryy here
weyy turkey
[Applause]
go number two number two number two
gobler now number two all the dogs are
extremely curious about this
situation oh
God turkeyy too crazy yeah oh they're
kind of wild so no wonder they're called
wild
turkeys same
spot every
time right got
him got him yep are you sure yeah say
get out I don't know how easy it is
to
Bullet this is not not our Thanksgiving
meal
four
three this is number
one we shut the gate babe we bed
banded three gobblers we got three
go bullet you cannot go in there buddy I
know it's
enticing isn't it AJ yeah
Mara hey girl
okay got
him bullet now so we got four
gobblers the next three are hens so
they're a little
uh the hens are a little bit uh got a
little bit more blood in them I guess
some wild blood and the
toms those Toms are the first ones that
come up and
eat they're first ones that come up to
you in the pin but those
hands they're a little bit of more
skittish yeah very
skittish so that one time my mayor may
not have let one of the turkeys out out
it was probably a Tom well yeah you hope
I think so the H are just a little bit
more little bit more
golly you going to take some of
those just give me a better home there
babe oh her band's about to come off you
want me to go get some BCE scripts or
something
07 yeah I'll see if
here hold on Brookie
[Applause]
you hey cor hey
girl gate gal you got
it shut it all the way make sure you
watch it she'll push it
open my Tru let me go get
them nothing like taking a turkey for a
stroll eh
hey
girl are actually kind of
pretty you're going to probably have to
do
this they have to put the camera down
yeah is that okay yep we keep the pliers
just in case we have back on seven
number
seven looks like the
girl girls are doing good looks like the
girls switch their posts huh
yeah are you turkey turkey door gal
now okay pullet get out
cut
whoa
thanks
love you just got to watch her cuz she
can open that gate
there got
her three we'll need those flowers too
i' get her other
Wing you want to take those Firs
I didn't know
they they
do why is
bleeding Brooks are you not Manning your
post let oh you're in trouble
[Music]
now open the gate for me she could have
in the cage I
it so it's
fine it's fine oh yeah they're
fine hold ons hold on
so we've got six in there so far two
hands four times this is the last hand
the hands like I said are the most
skittish and uh these suckers are
athletic and fast so it's hard to just
catch them it's easier if you get them
by both legs and then kind of drag them
and catch their body cuz they'll they'll
they'll get you were you transporting a
f
better oh she's F
bullet
man if you don't get their feet you
lose glad it's you and not me
see when you get them by their feet they
kind of come here come here here come
here come
here I got you let's see this number see
this number
four do their heads ever get like cuz it
looks almost like it's they're trying to
molting kind
of but
not it's like feathers are kind
of cuz these guys aren't even a year old
yet oh I see what you're talking about
the feathers on its neck I was talking
about all on its head kind of what yeah
I don't know will they come in or they
stay sort of blue like that on the hands
I don't
know look into one more hey Morgan
what's up
girl
cor sweet girl yes she is most of the
time feathers
how many how many you got let's see what
you got one oh well you got quite a few
in that hand multiple hands your fake
phone oh am I going to hold them now
hold on Dad's setting this one
free there they go two much bigger pin
four whoa that one's a big one isn't it
they're fluffy aren't they five seven
you got seven good job
babe Happy farmer pin right here mobile
turkey chicken unit Dr babe heck yeah so
we've got roosting bars right here here
back there all the diagonal are roosting
bars These Bars can be used to hang feet
off of right here and a water system and
so we're going to eventually have a
water system that'll
attach right here to this and it'll be
able to ran through there and it'll be
an automatic gravity flow water system
but right now we're in freezing temps
and we're not going to mess with it
right now
so excited about this so we can just pop
up the wheels and now since they're here
in our yard basically of the Ponderosa
we'll just be able to pick it up and
move it all throughout the yard here can
even go out in the pasture but we're
going to let them acclimate to this so
far because they've been in that small
pin for a while and deserve to be in
something bigger so I want to thank
happy Farmer for sponsoring our video
today we cannot wait to use this mobile
unit of course we're going to show you
guys keep you updated with it and we're
just happy to have our wild turkeys in
this new 10 x18 pin if you're interested
in a lightweight mobile chicken turkey
or duck unit check them out at happy
farmer.com these guys are little unsure
about what is going on hey
[Music]
Blackjack Maya where are you think
girl all
right hey
buddy thank you guys for watching us
we'll see you soon we keep on Bon
ranching